los comentarios de campaña de listos
sobre el presidente de Francia se han
hecho virales el presidente macron amigo
o Enemigo El Jurado aún no ha decidido
pero si me convierto en primera ministra
lo juzgaré por los hechos no por las
palabras
tras la secretaria de asuntos exteriores
del Reino Unido es considerada la
favorita para sustituir a Boris Johnson
como próxima primera ministra del país
pero la reacción a sus comentarios ha
sido rápida con críticas tanto de la
oposición como del propio partido
conservador en un Twitter diputado del
partido laborista David cuestionó su
criterio listo utilizando las últimas
semanas de su campaña de Liderazgo para
insultar al presidente de uno de los
aliados más cercanos de Reino Unido
muestra una lamentable falta de juicio
necesitamos un Primer Ministro que
trabaje por el interés nacional no que
intente ganar puntos baratos de la base
Tori por su parte el ex ministro de
asuntos exteriores y miembro del partido
conservador alistabeth calificó las
declaraciones de grave error los
comentarios también han sido noticia en
Francia con titulares de los medios de
comunicación como un amigo o un enemigo
visto
el presidente francés se mandió el
macron en visita oficial Argelia también
ha opinado
si Francia y Reino Unido no lo pueden
decir si son amigos o enemigos en mí
ese no es un término neutro Entonces
estamos abocados a graves problemas
macromania dio que sin duda Gran Bretaña
esta amiga de Francia sean quienes sean
sus dirigentes sin embargo las tensiones
entre los dos aliados de La otan se
mantienen Incluyendo los derechos de
pesca post brexit los cruces de barcos
de migrantes en el Canal de la Mancha y
un pacto militar entre Australia Estados
Unidos y Reino Unido que vio a Francia a
perder un jugoso contrató para construir
submarinos para cambera parísto calificó
de puñalada por la espalda y les estimó
la participación del Reino Unido
calificándolo como un socio menor de
Washington pero con la guerra en
ucraniana ambos países dicen estar
comprometidos a apoyar a kiev durante el
tiempo que sea necesario en la lucha
contra Rusia